- [Instructor] Let's
say that we've come up
with a new pill that we
think has a good chance
of helping people with diabetes
control their blood sugar.
When someone has diabetes,
their blood sugars unusually high,
that damages their body in
a bunch of different ways.
So we want to conduct
an experiment to test if
this pill really can help
people lower their blood sugar.
So the first thing we
need to think about is
how do we even measure or test
whether peoples' blood
sugar is getting lower.
Well, for our experiment,
what's typically done
is we measure folks hemoglobin A1C.
You don't have to worry too much
about this in the context of statistics.
But hemoglobin A1C test is a way
that's typically used to measure
your average blood sugar
over the last three months,
and we have whole videos on Khan Academy
explaining how that works.
So our hope would be that
our pill lowers peoples'
blood sugar which shows
up as a lowered A1C.
Now we have terms for this.
The thing that is causing
something else to change,
we call this the explanatory variable.
Explanatory variable,
and the thing that might get changed
by that explanatory variable, depending
on whether you take the pill or not,
we call that our response.
Response variable.
So now let's actually
conduct the experiment.
So what we would do is
we would go to the population.
Population of diabetics,
and we would want to take a random sample
from that population of diabetics.
A reasonably large one,
and later in statistics
we talk about what a good
size sample might be.
But let's say that we randomly sample.
Randomly sample
100 folks.
So we randomly sample 100 folks
from that population of diabetics,
and then you would want to assign
these folks randomly to
two different groups.
One would be your control group,
and this would be the group of people
who won't take the new medicine,
and then you would have
your treatment group.
These are the groups of folks
who will be given the new medicine.
The treatment group.
Now in some cases, you
can just randomly assign
these 100 folks between these two groups,
and one way to do it is you could give all
of them a random number
between one and 100
and then the top 50 go into treatment
and the bottom 50 go into the control,
or there's, you can use a
computer to randomly assign folks.
Now sometimes you might want to be
a little bit more sophisticated than that.
For example, there might be
evidence that someone's sex
might somehow influence
how they respond to a drug.
So what you could do is
something called block design
where, let's say, this group just happens
to have 60 females and 40 males.
One block design.
You can randomly assign,
but you can do it in a way
that you can ensure that
both of these groups
have the same proportions
of male and females.
So for example, if you
have 60 females here,
you can ensure that 30 of
them end up in the control,
and 30 end up in the treatment.
But you would assign those,
those 60 females randomly
between these two groups,
and similarly, you can do block design
of these 40 males, 20
end up in the control,
and 20 end up in the treatment.
So once you have folks
in both of these groups,
what you would probably want to do
is measure their A1C at the beginning.
You can view that as a baseline,
and then, over the
course of the experiment,
you would give the pill
to the treatment group,
and in the control group,
you might be saying,
well, we would just wouldn't do anything.
But the best practice is
actually to give a pill
that looks just like the real
thing to the control group.
This is known as a placebo,
and the reason why we do that
is there's definitely evidence
that when people think
they are taking a pill
that might help them,
that even psychologically it
can have an effect on them,
and sometimes it helps them.
This is known as the placebo effect,
and not only would you give both groups
a pill that looks the same,
even though this one
in the treatment group
actually has the medicine
in it, you also would
not want to tell folks
which group they are in.
When you don't tell them
which group they're in,
that's known as a blind experiment,
and you probably also don't
want to tell the people
who are administering the
experiment which group
they are administering, and
that's called a double blind.
So even the doctors or the nurses
that are administering the experiment,
when they're giving a
pill to the control group,
they don't know that
that pill is the placebo,
and you might say, well,
why is it important
for an experiment to be blind,
or especially double blind.
Well, that avoids, one, any
type of psychological effect
on the, from the point of the patient.
Or from the, say the
caregivers in this situation,
so that they don't kind of give it away.
They don't tell these folks,
hey, you're actually just
pretending to take a pill,
and so that ensures that
we minimize the amount
of influence or bias that might happen.
You might even have a
triple blind experiment
where even the folks who are
analyzing the eventual data
from this experiment don't
know whether they're analyzing
the data from the
control or the treatment.
They just compare the
two different groups.
But anyway, you do, you
people take the medicine
and the placebo over the
course of the experiment.
Maybe this lasts for three months,
and then you would want to
measure their A1C later,
and then you would see
their change in the A1C.
Now if you saw that there
wasn't really a difference
in the change in A1C between the control
and the treatment group, then you'd say,
well, that probably means
that my pill didn't work.
Now if you do get a greater reduction in
the treatment group, and you
do the statistical analysis
which we will learn in statistics
and you show that, hey,
there's a very low probability
that's happened purely due to chance.
Well then, you've got something.
You could probably conclude that
there is a causal connection between
taking the pill and
lowering your A1C level.
But once again, you cannot be 100% sure,
and so, this is why it's very important
for people to be able to
replicate your experiment.
Because what you'd want
to do either yourself
or other researchers might want to conduct
the experiment with different sample sizes
and different countries
and different populations,
maybe with different ages
at different times of year
to ensure that they
continue to see this result.